the population P of T of bacteria and a
petri dish
satisfies the logistic differential
equation the rate of change of
population with respect to time is equal
to 2 times the population times the
difference between 6 and the population
divided by 8,000 where T is measured in
hours and the initial population is 700
bacteria what is the carrying capacity
of the population and what is the
populations size when it's growing the
fastest
all right so in order to even attempt to
answer these questions and at any point
if you're inspired definitely pause the
video and try to answer it on your set
by yourself let's just remind ourselves
what we're talking about or what they're
talking about with the logistic
differential equation and the carrying
capacity so in general a logistic
differential equation is one where we're
saying the rate of change of and it's
often referring to population so let's
just stick with population so the rate
of change of our population with respect
to time is proportional to the product
of the population and the difference
between what's known as the carrying
capacity and the population now why is
this a model that you will see a lot and
especially why is it useful for studying
things like populations well what a
population is small the environment
really isn't limiting it and so assuming
it starts from some nonzero value this
thing is this thing grows this thing is
not going to get much smaller and so our
population is going to our rate of
change is going to increase and so let
me just draw a little graph here to show
the typical solution to a logistic
differential equation so this is our
population this is time so when our
population is low let's say it's gonna
start from some non-zero value if it was
zero what would happen well then our
rate of change would just be zero and
our population would never grow and that
makes sense if you have no bunnies on
your island and then there never will be
any bunnies on your island but if you
have a few bunnies well initially the
rate of change the the rate of
population is gonna keep accelerating as
this thing grows it's gonna keep
accelerating
but then at some point your environment
is going to limit how many bunnies for
example or bacteria can grow in your
environment because once the population
gets close to a this thing right over
here is going to approach zero and it's
going to make our rate of change smaller
and smaller and smaller and so you can
imagine in the limiting case as P gets
very very very very very close to a as P
gets very very very close to a you can
imagine as T approaches infinity our
rate of change is going to approach zero
so one way to think about it is our
population would asymptote towards the
carrying capacity that is a right over
here that is our carrying capacity so
there's a couple of ways of answering
this first question one way is we can
actually put our logistic differential
equation in this form and then we can
recognize what the carrying capacity is
the other way is to think about well
what happens as T approaches infinity as
T approaches infinity this thing
approaches zero and so we can think from
this logistic differential equation what
p values would make this thing be zero
based on this differential equation or
when this thing approaches zero what p
values would this approach so let's do
it both ways so one way let me write it
in this form right over here so it's
close this is 6 minus P over 8,000 can
we make it in the form or just have some
number minus P well if we multiplied
this times 8,000 and then we divided
this by 8,000 we wouldn't be changing
the value of that expression so let's do
that if we divide this by 8,000 you have
DP DT is equal to 2p over 8,000 is P
over 4,000 times and now let's multiply
this expression by 8,000 so 6 times
8,000 is 48,000 minus P over 8,000 times
8,000 is minus P and there you have it
we've written it now in this somewhat
classic form and we can see that the
carrying capacity is 48,000 I guess we
say 48,000 bacteria
so this thing right over here is 48,000
another way we could think about it is
well the carrying capacity is what
happens as T approaches infinity so as T
approaches infinity this thing right
over here approaches zero you can see
the rate of change approaches zero so
when that approaches zero
what does P approach so we can just
solve for this six minus P over 8,000
well there's two situations - PS for
which our derivative is equal to zero
there's one case when this is equal to 0
in which case our population is zero or
the other case is when this is equal to
zero so let's do that six minus P over
8,000 is equal to zero or we could say P
over 8,000 is equal to six and so we can
say multiply both sides by 8,000 P is
equal to 48,000 which is exactly what we
had right over there so now let's answer
the second part what is the populations
size when it's growing the fastest so
intuitively you can see when that is
right over here the population the rate
of change is going to grow grow grow
grow grow but then as we approach the
carrying capacity the rate of change is
going to start slowing down so your
maximum rate of change it's growing the
fastest is right about right about there
but how do we figure out it exactly well
you could go back to the logistic
differential equation you can see that
it's really our rate of change is a
function you could view it as a function
of our population right over here and
this is actually a quadratic expression
this is a concave downward quadratic
expression it would look like this if
you were graphing if you were graphing
rate of change let me do that if you
were to graph rate of change DP DT as a
function of population well when the
population is small so when the
population is say 700 or that's where
we're starting well let's just all speak
in generalities when your population is
small DPT
your rate is small but then it increases
and then some point around there it will
start the rate of
change starts to decreasing decrease and
it approaches zero as our population is
approaching the Chi the carrying
capacity so this right over here for
example would actually be our carrying
capacity so one way to think about well
what is this maximum point right over
here and there's a couple of ways that
you can approach it with calculus and
even algebra we have many tools for
identifying this maximum point which is
really just the vertex of this downward
opening this concave downward parabola
so let's just do that and let's find
this vertex and the vertex is just half
way between the zeros of this quadratic
so let's find the P values that make
this equal to zero which we actually
just figured out well the the maximum
point the vertex is just going to be
halfway between that so when the
population is zero our rate of change is
zero when the population is a which is
we know is 48,000 our rate of change is
zero and so our carrying capacity or
maximum rate of change is going to
happen halfway between those two points
which is 24,000 so it is a population of
24,000 when we got that by really just
saying well at what point does this
quadratic quadratic as a function of P
when does that hit a maximum point well
that's going to be halfway between the
zeros zeros happen when P equals zero
and P is equal to 48,000 so that's gonna
happen when the population is 24,000 so
this type of problem seems very
intimidating at first logistic
differential equation how do I actually
solve this and then analyze it but the
key is to 1 recognize a logistic
differential equation see what it's
talking about
and then maybe think of term think of
this in terms of our rate of change as a
function of our population and remember
that the carrying capacity is what
happens as R as T approaches infinity
and T as a as of T approaches infinity
our rate of change approaches zero and
so if that's approaching zero what must
our population be approaching